in chapter 5 of her biography Ellen
White documents down her experience of
being exposed to William Miller's Advent
movement and the resultant effects that
had upon her and her family who were
members of the Chestnut Street Methodist
Church she Begins by explaining the
traumatic head injury she suffered at
the age of nine and the impact that had
upon the rest of her life one of which
was feeling distant from God and hurt by
the Christians in her life who she felt
weren't there for her in her time of
need at times my sense of guilt and
responsibility God lay so heavy upon my
soul that I could not sleep but lay
awake for hours thinking of my lost
condition and what was best for me to do
the consequences of my unfortunate
accident again assumed gigantic
proportions in my mind I seemed to be
cut off from all chance of Earthly
happiness and doomed to continual
disappointment and
mortification even the tender sympathy
of my friends pained me for my pride
rebelled against being in a condition to
excite their
pity my Prospect of worldly enjoyment
was blighted and Heaven seemed closed
against me I had the highest reverence
for Christians and Ministers of the
Gospel but religion seemed too holy and
sacred for me to obtain an inconceivable
anguish bore me down until it seemed
impossible for me to longer live beneath
the burden I locked my secret agony
Agony within my heart and did not seek
the advice of experienced Christians as
I should have done no one conversed with
me on the subject of my soul's salvation
and no one prayed with me I felt that
Christians were so far removed from me
so much nobler and purer than myself
that I dared not approach them on the
subject that engrossed my thoughts and
was ashamed to reveal the lost and
wretched condition of my heart
well greetings and thank you for being
here tonight we're going to be diving
into the roots of the sth day Adventist
Church's war against the Christian faith
a conflict that traces itself all the
way back to the childhood of Ellen White
or Ellen Harmon as she was at that time
her early experiences planted the seeds
of what would grow into the movement we
see today which brought with it many
vestiges of her own experience in part
one we're going to unravel some of her
sad story witnessing the Journey of a
deeply troubled young girl whose inner
torment didn't just shape her own life
but gave rise to a movement that has
left Millions struggling with the same
turmoil including a deep-seated
hostility toward the Christian church so
stick around until the end because what
you're about to see is not just eye
opening but it will help you understand
the very Foundation of Adventist
thinking like never before but before we
get into it if you like what we're doing
here please consider partnering with us
at answering adventism tocom this
ministry is a viewer supported effort
that is only made possible by the
generosity and support of our YouTube
members and website Partners it is you
who makes it possible for us to have the
impact that we are seeing which is that
more and more Christians are getting
equipped and more and more Adventists
are being reached with the true Christ
in his gospel so if you would like to
take part in that and see it grow please
consider joining us the link to do so is
in the description box down below thank
you so much for your support all right
so as we heard Ellen White experienced
Church hurt upon her traumatic head
injury that she suffered at 9 years old
and this hurt ended up shaping her
future trajectory which actually brings
us to our first vestage of her own
psychology and pathology that has been
handed down to the movement today of the
chief charges made against those who
walk away from adventism is that they
were Church hurt that they didn't feel
loved Enough by those within the
Adventist Church resulting in them
leaving an example of this can be found
in their own annual statistics report
from 2022 where they hypothesized that
the 42% net loss in memberships that
they are experiencing must be due to
people not feeling loved or connected
enough because they can't fathom the
idea that people would leave over
theological differences nevertheless it
was Ellen White's own experience of
feeling uncared for that led her and her
Methodist Family to be open to millerism
and this is where the Story
begins in March 1840 William Miller
visited Portland Maine and gave his
first course of lectures on the second
coming of Christ these lectures produced
a great sensation and the Christian
church on Casco street that Mr Miller
occupied was crowded day and night no
wild excitement attended these meetings
but a deep solemnity pervaded the minds
of those who heard his
discourses Not only was there manifested
a great interest in the city but the
country people flocked in day after day
bringing their lunch baskets and
remaining from morning until the close
of the evening meeting Mr Miller dwelt
upon the prophecies comparing them with
Bible History that the end of the world
was near I attended these meetings in
company with my friends and listened to
the strange doctrines of the preacher 4
years previous to this on my way to
school I had picked up a scrap of paper
containing an account of a man in
England who was preaching that the Earth
would be consumed in about 30 years from
that time I took this paper home and
read it to the family in contemplating
the event predicated a great Terror
seized me for the time seemed so short
for the convers and salvation of the
world I had been taught that a temporal
Millennium would take place prior to the
coming of Christ in the Clouds Of Heaven
such a deep impression was made Upon My
Mind by the little paragraph on the
waist scrap of paper that I could
scarcely sleep for several nights and
prayed continually to be ready when
Jesus came but now I was listening to
the most solemn and Powerful sermons to
the effect that Christ was coming in
1843 only a few short years in the
future the preacher Trac bed down the
prophecies with a keen exactitude that
struck conviction to the hearts of his
hearers he dwelt upon the prophetic
periods and piled up proof to strengthen
his position then his solemn and
Powerful appeals and admonitions to
those who were unprepared held the
crowds as if
Spellbound so she found a scrap piece of
paper on the ground one day where an
Englishman was falsely setting
speculative dates and timelines for the
return of Christ to which as a little
girl she took the scrap piece home and
read it to her family she then began
contemplating the event that was
predicted by this preacher and great
Terror came over her and her words the
time of Salvation seemed short this
random scrap piece of paper made such an
impression upon her mind that she
couldn't even sleep for a few nights and
continually prayed to be ready for when
Jesus would return this is to say that
this idea that she read added fuel to
the fire of fear that was already
building within her as she noted earlier
in the chapter her life after her injury
left her feeling Unworthy of God's love
and fearful of his condemnation so it
was a scrap piece of paper from an
unnamed English preacher that laid the
foundation for her to be captivated and
impressionable to William Miller four
years later when he visited her town to
spread his theories now what's
fascinating about this is that she and
her family didn't seem to see any
problems with the idea of date setting
despite the new testment clearly
forbidding such practices instead they
were enticed by such making them
suscepti able to what would become a
very dark road ahead but she continues
by explaining how this looming feeling
of Terror and lack of love was only
heightened in the attending of William
Miller's
meetings special meetings were appointed
where Sinners might have an opportunity
to seek their Savior and prepare for the
fearful events soon to take place
terrible convictions spread through the
entire city prayer meetings were
established and there was a general
Awakening among the various
denominations for they all felt more or
less the influence that proceeded from
the teaching of the near coming of
Christ when Sinners were invited forward
to the anxious seat hundreds responded
to the call and I among the rest pressed
through the crowd and took my humble
place with the Seekers but there was a
hopeless feeling in my heart that I
could never become worthy to be called a
child of God a lack of confidence in
myself and a conviction that it would be
impossible to make anyone understand my
feelings prevented me from from seeking
advice and aid from my Christian friends
thus I wandered needlessly in darkness
and despair while they not penetrating
my peculiar Reserve were entirely
ignorant of my true State one evening my
brother Robert and myself were returning
home from a meeting where we had
listened to a most impressive discourse
on the approaching reign of Christ upon
the Earth followed by an Earnest and
solemn appeal to Christians and sinners
urging them to prepare for the judgment
and the coming of the Lord my soul had
been stirred Within Me by what I had
heard and so deep was the sense of
conviction in my heart that I feared the
Lord would not spare me to reach home
these words kept ringing in my ears the
great day of the Lord is at hand who
shall be able to stand when he appear
the language of my heart was spare me oh
Lord Through the Night Take Me Not away
in my S sins pity me save me for the
first time I tried to explain my
feelings to my brother Robert who was 2
years older than myself I told him that
I dared not rest nor sleep until I knew
that God had pardoned my
[Music]
sins so it's crucial to recognize that
these were the words of a young girl not
a mature woman yes Ellen pinned these
words as a mature woman but she was
speaking about a time when she was only
a young girl and from an early age we
see this tragic story unfolding a child
that's burdened by Deep spiritual
torment grappling with a profound sense
of unworthiness and sinfulness before a
holy God as she attended the fervent
Gatherings led by William Miller it
became evident that she never received
the only true remedy for such anguish
which is the Gospel of Jesus Christ
rather than finding the peace that the
gospel brings she was further steeped in
fear and fanaticism much like the scrap
piece of paper that set this course in
motion this serves as a sobering
reminder that had she been properly
catechized by her parents in the word of
God she would have recognized that those
who set dates for Christ's return
demonstrate their inability to rightly
handle the Bible and those people should
be avoided and this situation is Clear
Proof of why this is the case but
despite all this Ellen and her family
remained members of the Methodist Church
while also attending millerite meetings
however it was at a Methodist camp
meeting one summer in the 1840s that a
glimmer of hope appeared to touch her
soul in some of the tents meetings were
continued Through the Night by those who
were praying for freedom from sin and
the sanctification of the spirit of God
quite a number became sick in
consequence of the excitement and loss
of sleep and were obliged to leave the
ground these singular manifestations
brought no relief to me but rather
increased my
discouragement I despaired of ever
becoming a Christian if in order to
obtain the blessing it was necessary for
me to be exercised as these people were
I was terrified by such peculiar
demonstrations and at a loss to
understand them at length I was greatly
relieved while listening to a discourse
from the words I will go in unto the
king and if I perish I perish in his
remarks the speaker referred to those
who were wavering between hope and fear
longing to be saved from their sins and
receive the pardoning love of Christ yet
held in doubt and bondage by timidity
and fear of failure he counseled such
ones to surrender themselves to God and
Venture upon his Mercy without delay
they would find a gracious savior ready
to present to them the scepter of Mercy
even as ahasuerus offered to Ester the
signal of his favor all that was
required of The Sinner trembling in the
presence of his Lord was to put forth
the hand of faith and touch the skep of
his grace that touch ensured pardon and
peace those who were waiting to make
themselves more worthy of divine faith
before they dared venture to claim the
promises were making a fatal mistake
Jesus alone cleanses from sin only he
can forgive our transgressions he has
pledged himself to listen to the
petition and Grant the prayer of those
who come to him in faith many had a
vague idea that they must make some
wonderful effort in order to gain the
favor of God but all self- dependence is
vain it is only by connecting with Jesus
through faith that The Sinner becomes a
hopeful believing child of God these
words comforted me and gave me views of
what I must do to be
saved so upon attending this camp
meeting she saw all sorts of Hysteria
and fanaticism which caused her to
despair of even becoming a Christian the
theatrics and hysteria resulted in
people not sleeping resulting in them
being sick and having to be taken away
this led her to think that if that's
what one must do to be a Christian she
wanted nothing to do with it but amidst
all the chaos she says that she found a
sparkle of Hope from the Methodist
preacher who was there who called out to
those wavering between hope and fear
longing to have forgiveness of their
sins his counsel was to surrender
themselves fully to God and seek his
Mercy without delay all that was
necessary to find Mercy and pardon was
to reach out in faith and touch the
scepter of God's grace and it was these
words she said that comforted her and
gave her a clear picture of what she
must do to be saved so pretty simple
right well while she then goes on to
explain that this gave her hope in light
of the turmoil that she had been
undergoing she writes that this gave her
a new sense of exhilaration and
everything in the world seemed new fresh
and Alive her doubts had dissipated the
Gloom had been chased out by the
Glorious light of Jesus however this was
short-lived as she notes that doubts
fear and worry continued to plag her
mind despite this emotional experience
it was after this Methodist camp meeting
that William Miller came back to Maine
to give a second set of lectures in
which she found herself in
attendance in June
1842 Mr Miller gave his second course of
lectures in the CCO Street Church in
Portland I felt it a great privilege to
attend these lectures for I had fallen
under discouragements and did not feel
prepared to meet my savior this second
course created much more excitement in
the city than the first the different
denominations with a very few exceptions
closed the doors of their churches
against Mr Miller many discourses from
the various pulpits sought to expose the
alleged fanatical errors of the lecturer
but crowds of anxious listeners attended
his meetings while many were unable to
enter the house which was literally
packed I believed the solemn words
spoken by the servant of God and my
heart was grieved when they were opposed
or made the subject of justest I
attended the meetings on Casco Street
quite frequently and believed that Jesus
was soon to come in the Clouds Of Heaven
but my great anxiety was to be ready to
meet him my mind constantly dwelt upon
the subject of Holiness of heart I
longed above all things to obtain this
great blessings and feel that I was
entirely accepted of God Among the
methodists I had heard much in regard to
sanctification I had seen people lose
their physical strength under the
influence of strong mental excitement
and had heard this pronounce to be the
evidence of sanctification but I could
not comprehend what was necessary in
order to be fully consecrated to God my
Christian friends said to me believe in
Jesus now believe that he accepts you
now this I tried to do but found it
impossible to believe that I had
received a blessing which it seemed to
me should Electrify my whole being I
wondered at my own Hardness of Heart in
being unable to experience the
exaltation of spirit that others
manifested it seemed to me that I was
different from them and forever shut out
from the perfect Joy of Holiness of
heart my ideas concerning justification
and sanctification were
confused these two states were presented
to my mind as separate and distinct from
each other yet I failed to comprehend
the difference or understand the meaning
of the terms and all the explanations of
the preachers increased my difficulties
I was unable to claim the blessing for
myself and wondered if it was only to be
found among the methodists and if in
attending the Advent meetings I was not
shutting myself away from that which I
desired Above All Else the sanctifying
spirit of God so she notes that the
Christian churches for the most part did
not open their doors to host William
Miller in his meetings as she notes he
was regarded as a fanatic and a false
prophet and rightly so he was preaching
that Christ would return in
1843 and we see that despite her
riveting experience at the Methodist
camp meeting she still had no peace with
God her mind was constantly fixated upon
Holiness something she felt that she
lacked which resulted in her not feeling
accepted by God despite hearing all
about sanctification and Holiness from
the methodists she struggled to
comprehend what was actually necessary
for a person to feel at peace with God
to which her Christian friends tried
counseling her that she could be
accepted before God right now through
faith in Christ something she says she
tried to do but found it lacking ing
because she didn't experience an
electrifying feeling throughout her
entire being this was because what she
witnessed was others around her having
such an experience which left her
feeling shut out from experiencing
perfect Holiness of heart and then quite
tellingly she states that she didn't
understand the difference between
sanctification and justification a
problem that present 7th Day Adventist
theology also fails to comprehend it was
very clear that the overemphasis and
imbalance on Holiness and sanctification
that she experienced in methodism warped
her ability to find peace in other words
Ellen was never taught the law gospel
distinction as a quick note this is
exactly what 18th century Scottish
Theologian John cahun points out in his
book A Treatise on the law and the
gospel by the law here is meant the
moral law as a covenant of works and by
the gospel is meant the gospel in its
strict and proper sense to know the
difference so as to be able to
distinguish right between the law and
the gospel is of the utmost importance
to the faith Holiness and comfort of
every true Christian it will be
impossible otherwise for a man so to
believe as to be filled with joy and
peace in believing if he does not know
the difference between the law and the
gospel he will be apt especially in the
affair of justification to confound the
one with the other the consequence will
be that in his painful experience
bondage will be mixed with liberty of
spirit fear with hope sorrow with joy
and death with life if he cannot so
distinguish the gospel from the law as
to expect all his salvation from the
grace of the gospel and nothing of it
from The Works of the law he will easily
be induced to connect his own works with
the righteousness of Jesus Christ in the
affair of
justification and that is exactly
correct because young Ellen was never
taught the crucial distinction between
law and gospel her emotions became the
deciding factor in whether she felt at
peace with God which causes a person to
Teeter back and forth based on their
feelings this fundamental
misunderstanding is why when former
Adventists asked me for a new church
recommendation I cannot in good
conscience suggest the Methodist Church
even the theologically conservative
branches but nevertheless as Ellen's
spiritual turmoil deepened she
simultaneously was being taught that
hell was an eternal conscious experience
this only reinforced her fear that her
sins were too great to be forgiven
leaving her convinced that she was
doomed forever sending her into an even
further spiral she recalled that God was
portrayed to her not as a loving and
Merciful Savior but as a harsh Tyrant
who took pleasure in the suffering of
The Condemned this terrifying image then
plunged her into complete despair
leaving her feeling trapped in darkness
with no way out she says that she would
spend entire nights praying terrified
that if she died in her sleep she would
awaken in the horrors of an unending
Lake of Fire this overwhelming fear
eventually led to two significant dreams
in the first she says that she saw a
grand Temple where only those inside
would be saved those on the outside
would suffer people entered confessed
their sins before Jesus and were
pardoned causing a radiant light to
shine upon them but when Ellen stepped
inside a trumpet suddenly sounded which
shook the entire Temple then she says a
brilliant light filled the space and all
the other people vanished leaving her
completely alone in silence and darkness
she notes that she awoke from this dream
in agony struggling to convince herself
that it had only been a dream so rather
than easing her distress The Experience
only deepened her despair leading to yet
a second troubling
dream soon after this I had another
dream I seem to be sitting in abject
despair with my face in my hands
reflecting like this if Jesus were upon
Earth I would go to him throw myself at
his feet and tell him all my sufferings
he would not turn away from me he would
have mercy upon me and I should love and
serve him
always just then the door opened and a
person of beautiful form and countenance
entered he looked upon me pitifully and
said do you wish to see Jesus he is here
and you can see him if you desire to do
so take everything you possess and
follow me finally we reached the last
step and stood before a door here my
guide directed me to leave all the
things that I had brought with me I
cheerfully laid them down he then opened
the door and B me enter in a moment I
stood before Jesus there was no
mistaking that beautiful
countenance such a radiant expression of
benevolence and Majesty could belong to
no other
as his gaze rested upon me I knew at
once that he was acquainted with every
circumstance of my life and all my inner
thoughts and feelings I tried to Shield
myself from his gaze feeling unable to
endure his searching eyes but he drew
near with a smile and laying his hand
upon my head said fear not the sound of
his sweet voice thrilled my heart with a
happiness it had never before
experienced I was too joyful to utter a
word but overcome with ineffable
happiness sank prostrate at his feet
while I was lying helpless there scenes
of beauty and Glory passed before me and
I seemed to have reached the safety and
peace of Heaven at length my strength
returned and I
arose the loving eyes of Jesus were
still upon me and his smile filled my
soul with
gladness his presence filled me with a
holy reverence and an inexpressible ible
love my guide now opened the door and we
both passed out he B me take up again
all the things I had left without this
done he handed me a green cord coiled up
closely this he directed me to place
next to my heart and when I wish to see
Jesus take it from my bosom and stretch
it to the utmost he cautioned me not to
let it remain coiled for any length of
time lest it should become noded
and difficult to
straighten I placed the cord near my
heart and joyfully descended the narrow
stairs praising the Lord and joyfully
telling all whom I met where they could
find Jesus this dream gave me hope the
green cord represented Faith to my mind
and the beauty and simplicity of
trusting in God began to Dawn upon my
benighted
soul so all of this fear and torment
finally led to this moment
what started with a simple scrap of
paper spiraled into Relentless Terror
crippling anxiety and desperate prayers
nothing had been able to ease her
suffering not the fiery sermons at the
Methodist camp meeting not the Methodist
Church not the impassioned preaching of
William Miller two dreams in them she
encountered Jesus himself who spoke over
her to fear not a spirit guide then
presented her with a green cord a
mysterious object that is known within
the occult World regarding cord magic
allowing her to see Jesus whenever she
desired as long as she didn't allow it
to get nodded something else that is
known within cord magic and this dream
was what finally brought her Comfort not
the gospel not scripture but a mystical
encounter in a dream and an enchanted
green cord that was the moment that she
found peace or so she believed for those
that want to know more about this and
check out the primary sources and how it
Bears a striking resemblance to Green
cord magic check out this article on our
website the link to it is in the
description box down below so After
experiencing these two intense dreams
Ellen confided in her mother who
directed her to share this information
with a local millerite preacher Elder
Stockton Stockton had been preaching in
their Hometown in Maine and upon hearing
Ellen's story he responded with
something that would shape the course of
her life he told her that this was
indicative that God must have a special
work for her because that's why she was
experiencing this grave intensity at
such a young age and those words changed
everything for her that's what planted
the idea in young Ellen's mind that all
of her fear suffering and Visions
weren't just random experiences they
were divinely orchestrated this was
God's plan for her supposedly and it was
her purpose and with that the foundation
was set this moment would serve as the
turning point that would eventually
convince her that she had a prophetic
calling from God now she continues in
life sketches to note that she would go
go on to experience yet another
emotionally charged experience at a
prayer meeting that was held the same
day that she confided in Elder
Stockton an opportunity was not long
wanting there was a prayer meeting that
evening which I attended I bowed
trembling during the prayers that were
offered after a few had prayed I lifted
up my voice in prayer before I was aware
of it and in that moment the promises of
God appeared to me like so many precious
pearls that were to be received only for
the asking as I prayed the burden and
Agony of soul that I had endured so long
left me and the blessing of the Lord
descended upon me like the gentle Dew I
praised God from the depths of my heart
everything seemed shut out for me but
Jesus and His glory and I lost
consciousness of what was passing around
me when I again awoke to realization
I found myself cared for in the house of
my uncle where we had assembled for the
prayer meeting neither my uncle nor Aunt
enjoyed religion although the former
once made a profession but had since
backslidden I was told that he had been
greatly Disturbed while the power of God
rested upon me in so special a manner
and had walked the floor sorely troubled
and distressed in his mind when I was
first struck down some of those present
were greatly alarmed and were about to
run for a physician thinking that some
sudden and dangerous indisposition had
attacked me but my mother B them let me
alone for it was plain to her and to the
other experienced Christians that it was
the wondrous power of God that had
prostrated
me and it was after this experience that
she says she experienced a genuine
conversion for the first time she saw
God not as a harsh and tyrannical judge
but as a loving father obedience was no
longer driven by fear but out of joy and
gratitude everything felt new like it
did at that camp meeting her fears had
passed and a fresh sense of purpose
filled her heart now during all this
time her family was still attending the
Methodist Church and attending the
millerite meetings on the side the
millerites didn't have their own
churches it was something that people
would attend they would go to the prayer
meetings or the the lectures but then
they would still be attending their own
local church whether it was Baptist
Methodist Etc because millerism was an
ecumenical movement so they would hear
the teachings and then they would take
those back to their local church to try
and proze them but Ellen quickly noticed
that there was a stark difference in how
each group received her new enthusiasm
and Ellen was eager to share her new
found experience with both millerites
and methodists alike and this is where
things get interesting when she shared
her excitement with the methodists
especially her newf found Readiness for
Christ's imminent return she expected
them to Rejoice with her after all the
second coming had haunted her thoughts
ever since she stumbled across that
faithful scrap of paper years before but
instead of shared excitement she was met
with resistance a Methodist elder for
example dismissed her urgency telling
her that Methodist didn't believe that
Christ's return was imminent this
response stood in sharp contrast to the
fervor of the millerites and it only
deepened her connection to the movement
over and against
methodism when the presiding Elder
addressed others in the class he
expressed great joy in anticipating the
temporal Millennium of a thousand years
when the Earth would be filled with the
knowledge of the Lord as the waters
cover the sea he longed to see this
glorious period ushered in and appeared
to be in an ecstasy over the expected
event after the meeting closed I was
conscious of being treated with marked
coldness by those who had formerly been
kind and friendly to me my brother and I
returned home feeling sad that we should
be so misunderstood by our Brethren and
that the subject of the near- coming of
Jesus should awaken such bitter
antagonism in their breasts yet we were
thankful that we could discern the
precious light and rejoice in looking
for the coming of the Lord on the way we
talked seriously concerning the
evidences of our new Faith and Hope
Ellen said Robert are we deceived is
this hope of Christ soon appearing upon
Earth a heresy that ministers and
professors of religion oppose it so
bitterly they say that Jesus will not
come for thousands and thousands of
years if they even approach the truth
then the world cannot come to an end in
our day I dared not give unbelief a
moment's encouragement but quickly
replied I have not a doubt but the
doctrine preached by Mr Miller is the
truth what power attends his words what
conviction is carried home to the
sinner's heart
so when she says that the methodists
anticipated a temporal Millennium of a
thousand years she is referring to their
belief at the time in post-millennial
eschatology over and against
premillennial eschatology two varying
views of when the reign of Christ as
king over his kingdom will begin
historically Methodist theology held
that Christ is already reigning from his
throne in heaven his rule is not
something that begins after the second
coming instead the methodists of her
time were clearly influenced by the
Puritan es ketology of postmillennialism
which had shaped that region of North
America back in the 18th century
post-millennial esoy is optimistic about
the future and foresees that Christ's
present Rule and reign will bring about
a glorious future where the kingdom of
God will advance so successfully in all
the Earth leading to the vast majority
of the world being christianized and
coming under the rule and reign of Jesus
as king hence why they believe the
second coming is more than likely a ways
off into the future they don't set dates
and that it's not imminent there's a lot
left for the Christian church to do in
discipling the Nations well Ellen didn't
like this it didn't seem to fit with
what she was hearing at the millerite
meetings which focused on things getting
worse and worse and worse which was
indicative to them that the return of
Christ was soon to take place since the
methodists didn't accept that the world
was going to come to an end in the 19th
century she began to question whether or
not they were actually in the truth now
with hindsight we obviously see that
they were correct however as she notes
she had no doubt that Mr Miller had the
truth because his words carried great
power and brought conviction to Sinners
hearts and it was because of this that
her and her brother Robert determined
that they would continue to speak up at
the Methodist
meetings we both felt strengthened by
this conversation and resolved that we
would not be turned from our honest
convictions of truth and the Blessed
hope of Christ soon coming in the Clouds
Of Heaven not long after this we again
attended the class meeting we really
wanted an opportunity to speak of the
precious love of God that animated our
souls I particularly wish to tell of the
Lord's goodness and mercy to me so great
a change had been brought in me that it
seemed my duty to improve every
opportunity of testifying to the
unsurpassed Love of My Savior when my
turn came to speak I stated the
evidences I enjoyed of Jesus's love and
that I looked forward with glad
expectation to meeting my My Redeemer
soon the belief that Christ's coming was
near had stirred my soul to seek more
earnestly for the sanctification of the
spirit of God here the class leader
interrupted me saying you received
sanctification through methodism through
methodism sister not through an
erroneous Theory my heart was full of
love and happiness but I felt compelled
to confess the truth that it was not
through methodism my heart had received
its new blessing
but by the stirring truths heard
concerning the personal appearance of
Jesus through them I had found peace joy
and perfect love thus my testimony
closed the last that I was to bear in
class with my Methodist Brethren Robert
then spoke in his Meek way yet in so
clear and touching a manner that some
wept and were much moved but others
coughed dissenting and seemed quite
uneasy after after leaving the classroom
we again talked over our faith and
marveled that our Christian Brethren and
sisters could so Illy endure to have a
word spoken in reference to our savior's
coming we thought if they loved Jesus as
they should it would not be so great an
annoyance to hear of his second Advent
but on the contrary they would hail the
news with great joy we were convinced
that we ought no longer to to attend the
Methodist class meeting the hope of the
Glorious appearing of Christ filled our
souls and would find expression when we
Rose to speak this seemed to Kindle the
ey of those present against the two
humble children who dared in the face of
opposition to speak of the faith that
had filled their hearts with peace and
happiness it was evident that we could
have no freedom in the class meeting for
our simple testimony provoked snears and
taunts that reached our ears at the
close of the meeting from Brethren and
sisters whom we had respected and
loved so they once again sought to bring
up the millerite teaching that Christ
was going to return in 1843 only to be
met with disagreement and opposition
this prompted one of the elders to point
out that Ellen had experienced
sanctification through the message of
methodism and not William Miller's
theory of imminency to which her
response was what that no it actually
wasn't through Methodist preaching but
by these stirring truths of the imminent
return of Christ that she heard at the
millerite meetings but like we saw
earlier it was at a Methodist camp
meeting that the message of simple faith
in Christ could grasp hold of God's
scepter of mercy and a sinner could find
peace it was at this camp meeting that
she witnessed Christians finding such an
experience and she herself joined in
which resulted in her feeling as if
everything was new and she had found
pardon for her sins only it was fleeting
and it didn't last and why was that
because Upon a attending millerite
meetings after that experience Doom and
Gloom was once again impressed upon her
mind leading her back to the same
hopeless state that she had found
herself in years prior this then
culminated in two dreams where she was
supposedly given a green cord that she
could use to see Jesus whenever she
wanted and these two dreams are what she
said finally gave her hope not Miller's
preaching and not methodism two dreams
she had already said that the millerite
meetings while exciting filled with
despair because she didn't feel prepared
for the soon return of Jesus and this
would leave her up at night worrying
that if she were to die in her sleep she
would end up in the Eternal conscious
torment of hell that the Methodist
Church had taught her to believe in all
of this is what would lay the groundwork
for her disdain of the Methodist Church
as well as the Christian church at large
and it's what would make her primed to
accept that they were Babylon whom God
was angry with as we will see in part
two but she notes that after this
experience her family continued going to
millerite meetings because it was there
that they could focus on the imminent
Second Coming that was supposedly going
to take place in
1843 the Adventists held meetings at
this time in Beethoven Hall my father
with his family attended them quite
regularly for we greatly prized the
privilege of hearing the doctrine of
Christ's personal and soon appearing
upon Earth the period of the second
Advent was thought to be in the year 184
43 the time seemed so short in which
Souls could be saved that I resolved to
do all that was in my power to lead
Sinners into the light of truth but it
seemed impossible for one so young and
in feeble Health to do much in the great
work our family were all interested in
the doctrine of the Lord's soon coming
my father had long been considered one
of the pillars of the Methodist Church
where he lived and the whole family had
had been active members but we made no
secret of our new belief although we did
not urge it upon others on inappropriate
occasions or manifest any antagonism
toward our church however the Methodist
Minister made us a special visit and
took the occasion to inform us that our
faith and methodism could not agree he
did not inquire our reasons for
believing as we did nor make any
reference to the Bible in order to
convince us of our error but he stated
that we had adopted a new and strange
belief that the Methodist Church could
not accept my father replied that he
must be mistaken in calling this a new
and strange doctrine that Christ himself
had preached his second Advent to his
disciples he had said in my father's
house are many mansions if it were not
so I would have told you I go to prepare
a place for you and if if I go and
prepare a place for you I will come
again and receive you unto myself that
where I am there ye may be also this is
high Authority for our faith Jesus and
his Apostles dwell upon the event of the
second Advent with joy and Triumph and
the Holy Angels Proclaim that Christ who
has ascended up into heaven shall come
again this is our offense believing the
word of Jesus and his dis
deciples this is a very old Doctrine and
bears no taint of heresy the minister
did not attempt to refer to a single
text that would prove us an error but
excused himself on The Plea of a want of
time he advised us to quietly withdraw
from the church and avoid the publicity
of a trial we were aware that others of
our Brethren were meeting with similar
treatment for a likee cause and we did
not wish it understood that we were
ashamed to acknowledge our faith or were
unable to sustain it by scripture so my
parents insisted that they should be
acquainted with the reasons for this
request the only answer to this was an
evasive declaration that we had walked
contrary to the rules of the church and
the best course would be to voluntarily
withdraw from it to save a trial we
answered that we preferred a regular
trial and demanded to know what sin was
charged to us as we were conscious of no
wrong in looking for and loving the
appearing of the
savior so now we finally see what led to
the Harmons being disfellowshipped from
the Methodist Church she states that
while the Methodist Church did not
affirm the imminent return of Christ her
and her family still retained that
belief because of their continued
attendance at millerite meetings they
would only bring up millerism with
methodists in appropriate settings and
they weren't antagonistic in their
efforts to do so however this led to
their Methodist Pastor paying them a
visit to inform them that this was a
strange and new belief that did not
align with the teachings of the
Methodist church and it would probably
be best for them to withdraw their
membership quietly to which she says her
father responded by saying it's not
strange at all Jesus himself taught it
as did Paul the Apostle to their shock
the Methodist pastor had no scriptural
response and instead withdrew from the
situation and simply advised them to
leave the church without making a big
fuss but did you notice what she subtly
Twisted in this
retelling the millerites were preaching
imminency more specifically though they
were date setting for the second coming
proclaiming that it would happen in
1843 Ellen herself even noted this in
the narrative yet when she explains this
encounter with the Methodist Pastor she
portrays it as if they were
disfellowshipped for simply believing in
the second coming outright acting like
methodists were against this idea
altogether which is silly the Methodist
Church upholds the Apostles Creed which
very plainly states that Jesus is
returning turning to judge both the
living and the dead which is why article
3 of their 1784 articles of religion
plainly state that they believe in the
second coming it is simply paraphrasing
the Apostles Creed so if they weren't
actually disfellowshipped for believing
in the second coming then why were they
actually disfellowshipped an Australian
Man by the name of Keith moxen inquired
about this in 1988 where he wrote to the
Chestnut Street Methodist Church asking
about this in that letter which is dated
June 3rd 1988 they respond to him where
they wrote in part that the reason for
their dismissal was not that they
preached the second coming of the Lord
Jesus Christ that is a tenant of our
Orthodox Faith which is confirmed from
the articles of religion
1784 their dismissal was occasioned by
their breach of discipline in
proclaiming the views of William
Miller's time setting I read these
injuries to mean that after much quiet
counsil to refrain from their disruptive
behavior in church meetings the members
of Chestnut Street Church took what they
believed to be their only recourse to
dismiss the Harmon family they even
provided Mr moxen with a photocopy scan
of the church's records where they
include a note for why the Harmons were
disfellowshipped where it states that
the Harmon family was disfellowshipped
for long absence from our church and
ordinances and supporting an anti-
Methodist Doctrine and congregation
records of stewards and leaders of
Chesnut Street Methodist Church of
Portland Maine from February to
September 1843 regarding the case of
Robert Harmon unas Harmon Sarah Harmon
and Ellen Harmon ah so not quite the
same story that Ellen painted in life
sketches is it at least not the full
picture the truth is the Harmon family
wasn't disfellowshipped from the
Methodist Church simply for believing in
the second coming no they were removed
for actively spreading William Miller's
false date setting for Christ's return
the church Elders acting in their
god-given responsibility tried to
counsel the Harmons away from millerite
fanaticism but they refused to listen
1843 is what the Methodist Pastor was
saying is a new and strange belief not
the second coming outright and no Jesus
and Paul the Apostle did not teach that
the second coming was going to happen in
1843 instead the Harmons kept attending
millerite meetings and pushing their
deception within the Methodist
congregation ultimately this led to the
leaders having to take action and remove
them yet Ellen White's twisting of these
facts can still be found being pared by
Adventist to this day so let's have a
look at the doctrine of the literal
return of Christ it was rejected in 1844
it was rejected in 1844 it was rejected
in 1844 and this led to a
spiritualization of the doctrine of
Christ this is what I'm
writing and this opened the floodgates
for doctrines of demons to enter the
churches isn't that a terrible statement
to make it is unless it's true folks I
was even taught this same thing at
Adventist University that the SDA church
is the last true Bastion of Believers in
the entire world that believe in the
literal physical second coming of Christ
and all those other Christians out there
they've abandoned this biblical belief
and this Bible truth and it's just
utterly absurd and far from the truth
but here's the thing the Methodist
Church's decision to disfellowship the
Harmon family did not just change Ellen
White's personal path it was a part of
what ignited a spiritual war against the
Christian Church itself self which still
wages on to this day and in part two we
will see just how far this conflict
would go it all started with something
small a scrap piece of paper on the
ground that moment drove a troubled
young girl to confront the weight of her
sin yet she never truly grasped the
remedy despite hearing that salvation
comes through faith in Christ alone the
gospel never took root in her heart
instead she sought answers in all the
wrong places like two dreams and the
misguided teachings of millerism and
found more soulless in fanaticism and
paranoia and it was this painful
fractured Journey which would eventually
give birth to one of North America's
most infamous false prophets launching a
movement that continues to lead Millions
astray to this day you will not want to
miss part two where we dive deeper into
the story's next shocking chapter so
until then may Christ richly bless you
in the grace and peace won by him and
his vicarious death on the cross for
Sinners God
bless oh
apostate say
that come on man